hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control AC dot
l1-3.1.1 limits system access to
authorized users processes acting on
behalf of authorized users and devices
including other systems
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone try to understand all of this
dfar's nist SP 10171 and cmmc compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so here we here we go it's the very
first control you're looking at in cmmc
all right uh level level one level two
and let me tell you they don't want to
make life easy on you here with the
first control it's a doozy but today I'm
going to walk you through uh what this
is all about and what are the key
assessment points an assessor will use
to determine if you have met or not met
the requirements for this control and
then stay tuned because I'm going to
give you actual sample answers for each
assessment requirement Point by
assessment Point here we go okay so the
controlling question today is cmmc
control a
ac.l1-3.1.1 against first control really
you'll tackle says limit system access
to authorized users process is acting on
behalf of authorized users and devices
including other systems so if we're
actually looking at what the assessment
points are okay then what we find out is
the first thing you're looking for you
know that an assessor would look for is
they're going to say hey did they
determine if authorized users are
actually identified uh and you know if
we were to sort of think about that
maybe give a sample answer we'd say hey
authorized users are identified via
maybe active directory or a user login
system which is unique to the user right
everybody gets their own user ID or
unique identifier right you'll hear a
unique identifier later in these
compliance standards
uh and again that's kind of how we would
we would give a sample to that answer uh
assessment Point number two determine if
processes acting on behalf of authorized
users are identified
uh maybe we give a sample answer like
this all processes are identified via
system logs by the user executing that
process right because again if you look
in system logs it's always going to have
a username or a system username on who
it is that that executed that process
uh assessment Point number three
determinive devices including other
systems authorized to connect to the
system are identified so hey are the
devices identified uh again if I was
going to give you a sample answer I'd
say hey all devices accessing cui are
identified in I don't know let's say
active directory uh and of course system
log files right your system log is going
to tell you what device executed and
it's therefore you got some device
identification
uh the next assessment point they're
looking for is determine if system
access is limited to authorized users so
uh in this one we give a little
different kind of answer we're going to
say hey you know what per group policy
only authorize users within the
environment are those users uh belonging
to the cui handling organizational use
so only those users who belong to a
special group of users who are cleared
this handle cui are authorized to access
systems containing cui right so again
that's how we determine that it's
limited we limit it to a group of users
uh and again we clearly demonstrate that
through one of our systems or you know
again active directories got lots of
ways to sort of delineate down uh and
again you might have so maybe a regular
user administrative user and a cui
handling user and whatever the system
may be all right assessment Point number
one two three four and five determine if
system access is limited to processes
acting on behalf of authorized users uh
system access so yeah if I was gonna
give a sample answer I'd say system
access is restricted to only those users
and processes executed by those
authorized users which are allowed based
on group policy or maybe it's
system-wide policy or Access Control
list but they have to be limited somehow
you got to name what that policy is uh
and again that would be a good sample
answer and final one on this particular
control
determine if system access is limited to
authorized devices in other words do you
have a way to make sure that only the
devices you're authorizing can actually
access that information in this
particular case I'll just kind of give
you a sample answer and again this may
not be uh you know something that'll
work for you but again it's just a
sample answer we might say hey you know
what the IT department is only is is the
only issuing authority for devices which
are authorized to sign into systems like
maybe a domain right only only the sys
admin can actually sign you into the
domain those devices capable of
accessing cui are tokenized via
multi-factor authentication so again
great examples like Windows hello it
gives you a unique token once you've
successfully signed in under the right
user sort of settings and again it
allows you to have actual multi-factor
authentication in place as well and
again this is unique to only those
authorized devices only those authorized
devices and maybe they're part of a
domain maybe they're not but only those
devices which are tokenized using an MFA
token would actually be allowed to
access that data all right so first
control congratulations it's out of the
way right if you've got specific
questions here's the good news because
at on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this D fars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you and hey if you're looking for
more information on or help getting
compliant all right our compliance
experts are always on call for you you
can visit cmmc complianceecrets.com or
check out the bio below for links to get
to get help right now if you love the
content we're putting out for you help
us out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better smash that
subscribe button and get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance centers roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign
anyway